[Musique]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
au nom de mon groupe auquel je souhaite
associer la commune notre commission de
la défense
je souhaite avant tout rendre hommage à
la mémoire de nos soldats disparus
tragiquement dans l'accident
d'hélicoptère qui est intervenu au sahel
alors qu'ils étaient engagés en plein
combat contre des groupes djihadistes
armés chers collègues une fois de plus
nos forces paie un lourd tribut à cette
guerre qu avec un courage et une
abnégation sans limite elle livre pour
notre sécurité celle des français mais
aussi celle de toute l'europe
nos pensées douloureuses ont évidemment
aux familles de ces héros à leurs
camarades
alors camarades de peau de gap de vars
de saint christol mais aussi à toutes
les forces engagées au sein des opex qui
chaque jour partent en mission sans
savoir si elles rentreront le soir avec
une émotion toute particulière nous
penser notre affection vont ici à notre
collègue à jean marie qui nous parlait
si souvent de ce fils tant aimé dont la
vocation était le service de la france
écoutons le message de son père hier
soir nous sommes dévastés mais nous
sommes fiers de lui
car en vérité ces treize soldats
n'étaient pas là par hasard
il avait choisi cet engagement au nom
des valeurs auxquelles il croit
auxquelles il croyait en cet instant
nous ne leur devons pas de polémique
nous leur devons respect recueillement
et reconnaissance ici au sénat viendra
sûrement le temps des interrogations
elles sont légitimes peut-être aussi
faudra-t-il un débat mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous savons que face à une
extension de la menace djihadiste vers
les pays voisins
notre présence militaire est
indispensable je dirais même qu'elle est
incontournable car sans sécurité
inutile de croire au développement ou à
plus de présence sur le terrain d'un
état malien déjà si défaillant mais nous
savons aussi que cette mission sur un
territoire grand comme l'europe
nous ne pouvons l'assuré seul vous
l'avez dit monsieur le premier ministre
dpi nombreux nous est déjà mais ils nous
aident insuffisamment alors à la veille
de plusieurs sommets des nations
occidentales européen autant pensez vous
monsieur le premier ministre pouvoir
mobiliser plus encore nos alliés
européens et occidentaux afin qu'il nous
aide encore plus efficacement et qu'un
tel drame ne se reproduise plus jamais
en d'autres termes pour que pierre
emmanuel bockel et ses compagnons
d'infortuné ne soient pas morts pour
rien
[Applaudissements]
pour nous répondre
[Musique]
la parole à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président comment je n'ai
rien à ajouter à l'essentiel de la
question et de l'intervention voudrais
prononcer je mesure les motions de l'ami
est la parfaite compréhension que vous
avez de l'ensemble de ces sujets compte
tenu des responsabilités que vous
exercez au sein de cette assemblée
vous connaissez les militaires français
vous les voyez régulièrement ou les
auditionner ici voulait saluer sur les
théâtres d'opérations extérieures avec
beaucoup de sénateurs
j'allais dire vous partagez non pas du
tout en terme de combat et vous partager
avec eux la réalité de ce que sont les
opérations extérieures le sens de
l'engagement profond et en même temps la
très grande simplicité dans les rapports
humains qui prévaut généralement
lorsqu'on rencontre
celles et ceux qui servent sous les
drapeaux français bref monsieur le
président comme beaucoup d'entre nous
ici vous les aimez et donc la perte de
13 hommes est évidemment quelque chose
qui entraîne la tristesse et à certains
égards une forme de désarroi une forme
seulement car vous l'avez dit nous
sommes au mali pour d'excellentes
raisons sommes au mali pour garantir la
sécurité de la france pour accompagner
des états qui sont des états partenaires
et amis
nous sommes au mali parce qu'une
décision politique a voulu que nous
soyons au mali et comme toute décision
politique il est bien naturel que le
parlement l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat
la discute l'interrogent
ce que vous faites ce que vous faites
fait depuis longtemps et ce que vous
continuerez à faire et il est légitime
normal sain dans une démocratie qu'il en
soit ainsi
vous l'avez dit également monsieur le
président nous devons faire en sorte que
la france qui n'est pas seul au mali
puisse être plus accompagner encore
faire en sorte que les mandats de
l'ensemble des structures qui
interviennent soit probablement mieux
coordonnés faire en sorte que les
objectifs politiques et opérationnelles
soit adaptée au fur et à mesure que la
menace mute et se transforme
il appartiendra au président de la
république de s'exprimer après le temps
du deuil sur ce que nous pouvons faire
pour convaincre nos alliés nos amis
européens que l'intérêt de l'europe se
joue aussi dans cette région et il
appartiendra à l'ensemble de la
communauté nationale à l'ensemble des
acteurs du débat public de convaincre
nos partenaires sur place les états du
sahel qu'une partie décisive de la
solution est dans leurs mains que la
réconciliation nationale au mali la
reconstitution de l'armée nouvelle comme
on dit parfois au mali sont des
conditions indispensables du retour à la
stabilité de la préservation de la
stabilité et du développement que
l'engagement de l'ensemble des états et
le fait qu'ils assument avoir besoin de
nous d'autres pour garantir cette
stabilité soit toujours prier toujours
formuler c'est un combat difficile je le
disais tout à l'heure au sénateur alain
richard et c'est un combat qui est long
et nous le savons
il faut donc formulé politiquement les
objectifs
après débat convaincre nos alliés et
être au secours au soutien toujours des
femmes et des hommes qui s'engagent sous
les drapeaux
je vous remercie monsieur prix merci
monsieur me promener aux forces armées
viennent de subir la perte tragique de
treize militaires d'élite en action de
combat au mali nous inclinons devant
leur sacrifice
une rando hommage à leur courage est
celui de tous les hommes et femmes sous
nos armes l'opération dans laquelle nos
soldats sont engagés a été autorisé par
le parlement
conformément à la constitution et nos
commissions en sont tenus informés les
légitimes décidé en plein accord avec
les autorités du pays et elle apporte un
appui décisif à la force des nations
unies est chargé d'oeuvrer à la
stabilisation du mali nous déplorons
intensément la paire de rames de tram
atik de ces hommes de valeur mais nous
devons aujourd'hui voir aussi le sens
authentique de ceux de cette action de
leurs actions celui de l'action
internationale de la france il est
important que vous résidiez aujourd'hui
devant le sénat monsieur le premier
ministre les actions déjà menées par nos
forces contre nous nbi dans sa haine le
concours que nous apporte les nations
partenaires et la coopération développée
avec le mali et ses voisins pour
construire la paix dans cette région qui
est important à notre sécurité est à
monsieur le premier ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur avant de répondre à
la question que vous posez je voudrais
vous en doutez bien m'associer au
message de respect et de tristesse que
vous venez de formuler à l'attention de
nos compatriotes qui servent sous les
drapeaux à l'attention de leurs familles
de leurs compagnons d'armes à
l'intention de tous ceux qui mesurent
parce qu'il les connaît c'est parce
qu'ils en sont proches
le sacrifice qu'ils sont susceptibles de
faire et l'engagement quel engagement de
toute une vie qu'il réalise en servant
les armées françaises je le dis monsieur
le sénateur à quelqu'un qui le sait
mieux que d'autres
compte tenu des fonctions que vous avez
exercé
nous pouvons être fiers de nos forces
armées et je le dis avec un profond
respect une immense admiration au sénat
alors que nous savons tous que les
treize morts que nous devons déplorer
dans cette opération de combat au mali
touche particulièrement
cette maison cet hémicycle en la
personne de votre collègue de notre ami
jean marie bockel
la france se bat roumanie
plus exactement comme j'ai souvent
l'occasion de le dire dire la france se
bat au mali c'est dire en vérité
des hommes et des femmes se battent au
mali pour la france pour y défendre sa
sécurité pour garantir la stabilité
d'état amis alliés et partenaires
elle se bat au mali depuis que le
précédent président de la république a
considéré qu'il était de l'intérêt de la
france d'aller stopper cette avancée
vers bamako qui menaçait de déstabiliser
une région est de permettre la
constitution d'une zone de non droit
dans laquelle nous le savons
armés et terroristes se seraient
organisées afin de pouvoir ensuite
déstabiliser pas seulement la région
mais notre pays y compris par des
actions terroristes
des hommes et des femmes se battent donc
au mali d'abord dans le cadre de
l'opération serval puis dans le cadre de
l'opération d'arcane le sens de cet
engagement il est rappelé régulièrement
et je voudrais indiquer deux choses très
brièvement
d'abord le fait que la france n'est pas
seule elle est la première puissance par
la force la capacité numérique de son
engagement par la compétence des forces
armées qu'elles déploient sur ce
territoire
mais elle n'est pas seule et bien
d'autres nations participent soit dans
le cadre de la minus ma soit dans le
cadre des opérations organisées avec les
états de la région qui sont actifs dans
ce processus soit encore dans le cadre
de l'opération dite et utm ou des états
de l'union européenne participent à ces
opérations participe-t-il ac c'est une
question délicate et nous avons à
l'évidence un travail de conviction à
mener avec nos partenaires européens et
au delà avec nos alliés sur l'intérêt
commun que nous avons à faire prévaloir
des zones de paix de développement dans
la bande du sahel sous peine d'avoir à
subir ou chez nous en europe et partout
dans le monde
la déstabilisation que j'évoquais
précédemment
nous devons c'est l'objectif qui est
fixé aux forces armées françaises qui
participent aux opérations
nous devons déstabiliser les groupes
armés terroristes
nous devons déstabiliser leurs caches
d'armes une route d'approvisionnement
nous devons réduire leurs points forts
nous devons accompagner les armées des
états concernés et notamment ceux du g5
sahel dans la montée en puissance
indispensable
pour garantir la paix et nous devons
aussi nous le savons parfaitement ce
n'est pas facile faire en sorte que le
combat ne faut pas simplement militaire
car le combat militaire est nécessaire
mais il n'est pas suffisant pour régler
des questions qui se posent parfois
depuis très longtemps dans cette région
il ya donc tout un travail de
stabilisation politique qui revient
souvent aux états concernés et de
développement économiques de perspective
pour l'ensemble des populations
ce que je veux dire monsieur le sénateur
en vous répondant ainsi c'est que le
combat que nous livrons est un combat
militaire dure et risquaient tous ceux
qui servent dans les armées françaises
savent les risques auxquels ils
s'exposent parfois dans la vie civile et
je ne parle pas de cette assemblée bien
entendu parfois dans la vie civile on
oublie les risques auxquels s'exposent
nos soldats on ne les voit pas très bien
on les mesure pas complètement tous ceux
qui s'engagent sous les drapeaux les
connaissent ça ne rend pas le risque
moins intense et ça ne rend pas le
chagrin moins fort mais c'est un risque
qui est connu et que prennent
consciemment des jeunes gens au service
de la france
nous devons en être fiers et les
célébrer nous devons accompagner ce qui
reste des conjoints les enfants les
parents les accompagner de la chaleur de
notre fraternité et nous devons savoir
que ce qui se joue là bas est important
pour nous ici et que ce combat sera long
et difficile
l'honneur d'une démocratie c'est de
faire en sorte que le pouvoir politique
choisisse d'engager des troupes sur un
théâtre d'opérations étrangers
lorsqu'ils considèrent que c'est
nécessaire c'est une lourde
responsabilité
et elle a été lourde pour tous ceux qui
ont exercé ces choix l'honneur d'une
démocratie c'est aussi de dire la fierté
que représente pour nous tous ces hommes
et ces femmes et j'ai bien conscience
monsieur le président quand dix ans ces
mots je suis un peu maladroit mais je
peux vous dire mesdames et messieurs que
je suis infiniment admiratif et que nous
sommes tous infiniment admiratif de ce
qu'ils font sur place
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole monsieur monsieur richard dont la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
olivier léonard pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre
notre émotion l'émotion nos concitoyens
est à son comble depuis l'annnonce de la
mort de nos treize soldats dans cette
collision de deux hélicoptères au cours
d'une opération de combat au mali ce
lundi 25 9 ans aux dons de tous les
collègues de mon groupe je souhaite
rendre hommage au courage de ces héros
qui ont péri l'an ensemble dans cette
tragédie
je tiens à honorer leur mémoire et je
veux adresser notre soutien le plus
profond aux familles endeuillées
j'ai naturellement une pensée
particulière pour notre collègue jean
marie bockel et sa famille à cet instant
est alors qu'un hommage national sera
rendu lundi aux invalides
il m'apparaît très crucial de réaffirmer
notre soutien aux 4500 soldats engagés
sur le terrain pour combattre le
terrorisme islamiste qui nous frappe
aussi ici en france et en europe
par delà les débats que certains
voudraient engager sur la stratégie de
la france dans la région du sahel
je rappeler deux choses deux choses à la
fois simple et pourtant fondamental sans
l'opération barkan le mali a mis pays-là
ami de la france serait aujourd'hui sous
la domination de nos ennemis cas romani
la france fait face
trop seul à l'organisation des états
islamiques au grand sahara c'est
d'ailleurs sur ce dernier point que je
souhaite vous interroger monsieur le
premier ministre
dans un contexte de dégradation de la
situation sécuritaire dans la région du
sahel
et alors que la france protège toute
l'europe
dans cette opération quelles initiatives
comptez vous prendre pour obtenir un
soutien militaire renforcé de la part de
nos alliés européens qui sont de fait
directement concernés quelles
initiatives diplomatiques et politiques
la france prend tel auprès de l'union
européenne et de l'organisation des
nations unies pour avancer vers une
stabilisation économique et
institutionnelle dans cette région pour
vous répondre la parole qu'à madame la
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
désormais même geneviève darrieussecq
que vous avez la parole madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur léonard
je tiens d'abord à excuser l'absence de
florence parly qui a tenu à se rendre au
mali aux côtés de nos forces armées
suite au drame et aux déchets de nos
treize militaires français qui ont
trouvé la mort lundi au cours d'une
opération de combat contre les groupes
armés jihadistes dans le liptako malien
je voudrais vous remercier je voudrais
remercier la représentation nationale
ici pour votre soutien indéfectible pour
nos forces armées et je dois vous dire
que notre ministère et la communauté de
défense est très sensible au soutien de
la nation dans les moments difficiles
mais aussi tout au long de l'année
monsieur le sénateur la france reste
plus que jamais engagée aux côtés du
mali
nos axes d'effort à court terme c'est
d'abord soutenir les armées locales et
la force du g5 sahel et outre notre
soutien équipements cela passe par des
opérations conjointes comme l'opération
bourgou 4 menée justement ces dernières
semaines est appuyé par barkan qui a
permis et bien de neutraliser nombre de
terroristes et qui a permis de saisir de
très nombreux équipements la france veut
mobiliser les européens pour lancer la
taskforce takouba déploiement de forces
spéciales européennes à l'accompagnant
un accompagnement des maliens et
monsieur le premier ministre vient de le
dire la solution n'est pas que militaire
l'accord de paix doit être mis en oeuvre
et nous devons progresser en matière de
gouvernance et de développement
c'est au gouvernement malien qu'il
appartient de jouer un rôle moteur
son engagement à désarmer toutes les
milices et aller au bout du processus de
désarmement démobilisation et
réinsertion doit être suivi d'effets
nous sommes la france est prête à aider
les maliens à faire face à la crise du
centre est le premier ministre malien
s'est rendue dans le centre et a permis
la signature d'accords locaux ce qui
étonne pas supplémentaire le retour de
la sécurité de la justice est impératif
mais il faut également traiter les
causes profondes en appuyons leur
déploiement accéléré de l'état et des
services
c'est la priorité de notre appui
notamment avec l'alliance au sahel
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
notre collègue pierre louault pour le
groupe de l'union centriste lever la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture il ne vous
aura pas échappé qu'aujourd'hui
à paris comme dans un certain nombre de
villes françaises nos agriculteurs sont
dans la rue après l'espoir portèrent
travers la loi dit et galim et les états
généraux de l'alimentation les
agriculteurs de notre pays sont amenés à
constater que les résultats ne sont pas
à la hauteur des espérances qui l'ont
nourri et que collectivement nous
voulons leur donner depuis tant d'années
une réalité nous rattrape encore est
toujours celui des prix agricoles
monsieur le ministre monsieur le premier
ministre fait de la responsabilité de
votre gouvernement
aujourd'hui il y a quatre cent cinquante
mille français qui se lèvent tous les
matins feeder qui travaillent sept jours
sur sept et qui pour moitié ne gagnent
même pas le smic et pour un quart
d'entre eux ont des revenus inférieurs
au rsa et pourtant ce sont ces milliers
de paysans qui nourrissent les 68
millions de français de nos concitoyens
et ont pour seul retour les attaques des
doctrinaires environnementaux
et animalistes les agriculteurs font des
efforts considérables
ils ont acquis une grande capacité de
remise en cause comme peu dans notre
société les pratiques agricoles évoluent
pour améliorer la qualité des produits
la disparition du glyphosate détruire
les espoirs des agriculteurs et
notamment ceux qui sont les plus
performants sur la conservation des sols
malgré tous ces constats le phénomène
d'agri bashing s'acharne mitraille a
refait de l'agriculture de ce pays
monsieur le ministre comment redonner
une raison de vivre aux agriculteurs
comment leur permettent de gagner leur
vie
comment redonner une raison d'être face
à ses bourreaux des agriculteurs qui les
emmène tout droit au suicide
pour vous répondre la parole et
communistes de l'agriculture que
l'alimentation didier guillaume sur le
ministre avait la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur lourd aujourd'hui selon le
comptage du ministère de l'intérieur
1086 tracteurs sont sur paris c'est un
trait aux chiffres et c'est une très
grosse mobilisation de même que dans
beaucoup de capitales régionales il y a
beaucoup de manifestations et de blocage
pourquoi et vous l'avez dit dans la
deuxième partie de votre question tout
simplement parce que les agriculteurs en
ont marre du dénigrement permanent
les agriculteurs je vais je vais venir
les agriculteurs les agriculteurs en ont
marre de se faire insulter
lorsqu ils dépendent dans un champ les
agriculteurs en ont marre d'avoir eu
soixante dix agressions attaques dans
des élevages y compris par des
parlementaires de la république madame
la présidente et les agriculteurs et
encore ce week-end trois bâtiments
d'élevage ont été brûlés c'est
inacceptable et il faut le condamner
fermement et toutes celles et tous ceux
qui trouveront des explications à cela
seront complices de la détresse et de la
grille bashing donc ça c'est la première
chose
deuxièmement ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que
nous essayons de travailler pour qu'ils
aient un revenu décent
mais aujourd'hui la grande difficulté
dit à pour l'agriculture c'est que les
agriculteurs sont la seule profession en
france qui ne fixe pas leurs prix la
seule profession qui vend en dessus en
dessous de ce que ça leur coûtait c'est
inacceptable etc et c'est pour ça c'est
pour ça que mais j'aurais pu mais je
répondrai à madame la présidente prime à
tout à l'heure
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est la
raison pour laquelle les ce qui a été
fait dans le cadre de la loi et galim
n'avait jamais été tenté jusqu alors
c'est l'inversion de la construction des
prix pour y arriver ça a été décidé par
toute la profession agricole
quand fondu décidée par les
parlementaires par les états généraux et
de sueur de le mettre en oeuvre je vous
remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à madame
la présidente sophie primas pour le
groupe l'est républicain
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture nous avons
dans ce pays une chance insolente c'est
celle de notre pays qui dispose d'une
situation exceptionnelle pour que notre
agriculture puisse répondre à bien des
enjeux souveraineté alimentaire
transition écologique sécurité sanitaire
nouvelles énergies
mais nos agriculteurs sont aujourd'hui
perdu totalement perdu et la colère qui
monte aujourd'hui à paris autour de
paris est un cri
monsieur le ministre notre agriculture
est en grande difficulté alors ma
question est simple comment comptez vous
répondre aujourd'hui à la détresse des
agriculteurs dans la rue on vous
répondra parole étant ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
présidente
dans cet hémicycle j'ai travaillé à
trois lots agricole à la lm ap de bruno
le maire le clip de la loi c'était dreux
données du revenu aux agriculteurs à la
loi d'avenir de stéphane le foll dans le
titre était il faut que les agriculteurs
vivent de leur travail et daloa et galim
de stéphane travert en disant on va
inverser la convention des prix eh bien
je suis au regret de dire que depuis 15
ans tous gouvernements confondus
la france n'a pas réussi à donner un
revenu décent à ses agriculteurs
et c'est là le drame de c'est là le
drame alors je pense que nous
participons tous à cela et c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans le cadre de la
loi et galim dans le cadre de la loi et
galim un pari a été tenté c'est le pari
de l'inversion de la construction des
prix c'est le pari de faire en sorte que
soient les filières qui fixent leurs
prix et j'ai remarqué d'ailleurs dans
l'excellent texte que vous êtes qui est
en préparation que vous ne revenez pas
là dessus dans votre ppl madame la
présidente
c'est dire si le choix qui a été fait
aux états généraux et dans la loi et
galim d'inversion de l'action de la
construction des prix co construit avec
les syndicats agricoles vous va vous n'y
revenez pas vous avez raison
pourquoi vous avez raison d'une paille
revenir parce qu'il ya deux ans
d'expérimentation et vous savez très
bien que l'année dernière la loi n'était
pas en application les ordonnances
n'était pas prise et donc ça ne pouvait
pas fonctionner la deuxième année
d'expérimentation c'est cette année la
présidente de la fnsea langrand dit la
semaine dernière c'est cette année qu'on
verra ça fonctionne et si ça ne
fonctionne pas alors il faudra y revenir
mais moi je crois à l'intelligence
collective
je pense que nos entreprises de
l'agroalimentaire qui font du bon
travail vont pouvoir avancer je pense
que la grande distribution va pouvoir
payer différemment les choses mais je
crois surtout mais je crois surtout mais
je crois surtout que la mobilisation
d'aujourd'hui des agriculteurs je vais
devoir partir parce que je les reçois de
chaleur va contribuer avec le travail
des parlementaires et du gouvernement à
faire évoluer cette situation
madame la présidente vous utilisez
l'agriculture votre réponse me déçoit
car il ne s'agit pas de la loi et gally
mais il s'agit du destin de
l'agriculture est ce que je pointe
aujourd'hui c'est les contradictions
entre le discours et les actes qui sont
à mon avis au coeur du malaise agricole
vous dit soutenir la transition
écologique mais rien dans votre budget
pour accompagner significativement une
modification profonde des modes de
production
vous mettez en place une interdiction
des produits phyto mais rien pour
certaines filières dans l'impasse comme
le souligne votre propre majorité
vous avez fait adopter la loi et galim
censé sauver le revenu agricole
mais elle ne porte que sur 20% de ce
revenu et la théorie du ruissellement ne
fonctionne pas vous tenez vous dit
soutenir la compétitivité des
exploitations mais la même loi augmente
les charges et le différentiel est
devenue insoutenable et nous n'avons
jamais autant apporter vous pariez sur
la montée en gamme et vous soutenez les
accords commerciaux qui ouvre nos
marchés à des produits qui ne répondent
pas aux exigences de production c'est le
cas du ceta et c'est le cas la ddt de
l'accord sur les viandes bovine
américaine que le parlement européen
s'apprête à voter demain vous dit
préparer l'avenir mais vous laissez le
se préparer une pac avec une
renationalisation des budgets qui
favorisera une concurrence
intra-européenne mortifère monsieur le
ministre je crois sincèrement qu'il nous
faut une grande loi
un grand projet de loi de programmation
pluriannuelle agricole dans lequel nous
parlerons de l'innovation de la
formation des investissements durables
et qui offrira un cap à nos agriculteurs
une ambition à notre pays un cap qui
donnera confiance à nous français qui
oublie trop souvent quel est notre
chance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]